[Music]
you have this new show mom with allison
janney yes you guys must be getting
along because you just tweeted out this
picture of the two of you so you tweeted
that out I did yeah and I said something
like I love my mom and she tweeted the
same thing she said I love my daughter
yeah but she's amazing and we have a
great time and we both play women that
were teen moms and you know now we're
recovering addicts and it sounds
hysterical right but no it's I love that
we it's a comedy but we touched on sort
of these these deep issues and it's
issues that a lot of people are dealing
with yeah we have a we have a clip here
from anything we need to know for this
or is it I've had a really bad day and
my mom has come over to cheer me up oh
that always goes well yeah let's say
okay this good from mom knocky knocky
hi how's your little boss oh I broke his
leg and his nose admitted it felt pretty
good didn't it Oh a little bit I got you
a gift
Thanks vacation well I know you don't
feel ready to date for a while I thought
this might put a little spring in her
step what is it
[Applause]
thank you you mind vision edition my
pleasure I am such a good mother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mondays at 9:30 on CBS you bring your
little guy to the set sometimes no I get
too distracted if he's there you know
but but maybe maybe one day if that
happens but I love ya I just loved it
it's a kind of a dream job this show and
you know we shoot right there I'm gonna
come bug you all the time I will just do
any and I can do unscripted walk-ons
literally when we're just ourselves and
we walk in and look around and then keep
walking yeah we we can really be the
annoying neighbors yeah are you guys
shooting something professional Wow
that's not really your mom yeah
that's out - Jenny you can't fool